Before we say goodbye,
we like to play a quick round of...
Drewth or Dare.
(Drew grunts)
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
All right. All right.
In our audience, we have Brittany Leslie.
Hi, Brittany.
Hello. How are you guys?
I love that (indistinct) it's Brittany
and not Britney.
Britney, yes.
All right, so what's it gonna be, a Drewth or a dare?
It's a Drewth.
All right, what is it?
I have a horrible habit
of never putting away my clean laundry.
I want to know what is one bad habit
that you're each trying to break?
Okay, you know when you open your phone
and you see, like, how many emails you have left to return?
Mm-hmm.
Mine is over 90,000
of unread emails.
(audience gasping)
And so (chuckles), I know,
that's how I feel every morning that I look at it.
My new year's resolution two years ago was to respond
to every single email that I ever got;
I did not do that.
(audience laughing)
So I'm gonna break that habit. That's a habit I gotta break.
I think you should refresh
and delete and start from the beginning,
so you have a chance at success.
Okay, maybe I'll do that instead.
Okay. Thank you.
(audience laughing)
Okay, I am having an epiphany in my life right now
that the critical voice is something
that I would like to avoid.
Everything I say to myself, the way I talk
to myself is so critical,
so I'm having this critical-voice epiphany
where I'm wanting to stop it, and I am gonna squander
that you-know-what like nobody's business
for once in my freakin' life,
(audience cheering)
(audience clapping)
because it's so not me.
Thank you, Brittany.
(upbeat music)